[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is
Charles Xavier help is on the way doing
space missions now cool we get the
astronauts we bring them home
go heat signatures rising fast we gotta
get out of here please Jean where is she
she should be dad did you hear what the
kids are calling you
Phoenix hello gene who are you the
better question is who are you
something's happening to me you would
lose control bad things happen but it
feels good that power destroyed
everything that ever came into contact
with until you
with x-men fear you
and what they fear we seek to destroy
shockula's ooh
go die
she's still off that she's not Jean
anymore
threatening me that's right
it's a simple extraction we go into
space we get the astronauts we bring
them home any questions yeah like a
thousand we don't have time for a
thousand doing space missions now cool
let's go
[Music]
that's a solar flare you know I've never
seen a reading like this kuretake Peter
go
right back
[Music]
this land was given to us by the US
government we have no intention of
taking it back we're not here for you
looking for one of the x-men Jean Grey
look and all you are I don't want to
fight
now you don't
it's not that I said stop that right now
it's not me it's me g-gee
[Music]
who are you the better question is who
are you
are you scared little girl who answers
to a man in a chair are you the most
powerful creature on the planet
I don't know who I am yes you do near
the girl who everyone abandons
maybe they had good reason because
what's inside you you're afraid of it
because you think it makes you bad evil
all the words you've been taught to keep
you in line where it's created a very
long time ago by men with very little
minds they can't begin to comprehend
what you are even your x-men you can't
well front
stay out of my way I'm sorry what you
did I can't let you go in there you're
always sorry Charles
and there's always a speech but nobody
cares anymore we do this here now
they'll see us as monsters violent
freaks fighting on the streets of New
York
what did I tell you damn it man your
homeland will be gone everything you
care about save it don't do this Eric
the girl dies when very first x-men came
out nobody saw it coming
it was like okay this is something new
the world said for seeing something
different here learn and I hear in my
school for the gifted
I play Professor Xavier gray magneto
Raider Cyclops storm
whole cast really elevates the material
I hear you're quite an animal look who's
talking
the history of the franchise I hope
would be a legacy that we satisfied the
legend of these characters what makes
all the mutants and x-men so beautiful
that we're all different they're kind of
outcasts but we join together very first
x-men changed comic book movies the
thing about x-men that separation from a
lot of the other superhero movies as the
emotion that is find within the
relationships this is what life looks
like people love each other
[Music]
beyond the fantasy of these characters
something intrinsically human about them
something's happening to me the dark
phoenix towers and consume that becomes
the ultimate battle the world of the
x-men would never be the same
she's not Jean anymore it's just really
exciting to be a part of something that
people have loved with generations we
couldn't ask for better more dedicated
fancy you're not kids anymore
not students your x-men make no mistake
my brothers when the air is still and
the night has fallen the question is who
would you stand with
we must unite and fight as one or perish
the right to fear me
[Music]
you think you can fix me gene you are
not broken
eautiful friend
the mind is a fragile thing takes only
the slightest tap to tip it in the wrong
direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are
she's changing to what you didn't come
here looking for answers you came here
looking for permission
she's one range
Payne missile coming out to us Jean lost
control is she still a friend this is
your fault Charles the world is on the
brink I'm sorry I didn't stop it sooner
you're always sorry Charles
and as always a speech and nobody cares
they're still
don't do this
[Music]
the right to family I've seen Abel
[Music]
I'm looking at it now what is this place
welcome to the school for the gifted
we are now seeing the beginnings of
another stage of human evolution
the truth is mutants are very real and
they are among us
here you have the chance to be part of
something much bigger than yourself
forget everything you think you know
you're not kids anymore
[Music]
you're x-men wars still coming charms
and I intend to fight it you ready for
this and you tomorrow starts today the
world is on the brink
she's changing
to what
when is control
but it feels good
[Music]
tell me how we fix this truck I don't
know what to do that's right
the right to fear me
[Music]
the interesting thing I realized writing
the x-men is I always had a sense of
where I was going with dark Phoenix Jean
had the greatest power imaginable and
how she's going to deal with that that
was the thing I learned I guess from
Stan you know actions have consequences
ok that was always in the back of our
mind we wanted to demonstrate what she
could do and she ended up saving the
universe they wanted her to be the heart
and soul of the team and we also wanted
to put Scott in this place his work is
so character oriented and - so character
Orion and I think that's one of the
reasons that were very simpatico the key
was creating characters who were as
relevant and real to the audience's I
could make them put them in situations
that everybody could identify with and
recognize what I started with Marvel I
was in school my parents knew al Jaffe
and he said Oh does he have any interest
in comic books and the next thing I know
the phone rings and I pick it up as hey
they're true believer this is Stanley
you don't bow so I hear you want to work
for Monell Comics yes
Stan had a mantra there are three rules
get your book in on time make sure it's
good don't be a pain in my ass any two
out of three you got to keep your job in
Dark Phoenix Jean found herself wrapped
up in a series of circumstances that she
was unprepared for she makes a moral
choice and for better or worse that's
the only way she can find to make amends
for what she's done
Jean was his holy favorite I think
partly because he had given her such a
hard time through so many issues and
he'd seen how strong she could be
for me as a writer I want them to fall
in love with these characters I want
them to see them as real echoes or
parallels with their own lives
Dark Phoenix is the ultimate expression
of the darkest shadow and everyone sold
and there you go why did you make me do
that look at me focus on my voice I'm
not giving up on you Jean she was my
friend you're my family James no matter
what
look
you're special gene and if you stop
fighting that force inside you
boom Grayson he will possess the very
power of a guy shockula's all tell me
how we fix this trough tell me what to
do I don't know what to do
no they don't understand stay fear and
what they fear we seek to destroy
it's your fault Charles tries to protect
I'm scared
when I lose control bad things happen to
people like the girl dies she's still
Jean we can still help her
sometimes you want to believe people as
something that they are not
by the time you realize who they are
it's too late
she's coming
[Music]
[Music]